Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to raft.
now if you remember raft, it was an exercise into seeing how lonely and
crazy, I could get on my own in the middle of the ocean
but this game has been extremely updated many of you are like
Oh, it just ended at 1.05 back in the beta. But in actuality this game has been worked on non-stop ever since
Oh, I get to grab my own character.
Oh...
I could choose between Maya and Rouhi.
Maya, Rouhi (x6)
*INHALE* (boi)
Rouhi Maya Rouhi Maya
Roumamemamomamemame
*Singaplier* best singer 11/10
I can't make a decision on my own?
Why is.. Why is  this such a tough decision for me? I thought I...
Usually I'm just like " Oh you can pick one or the other" but I juhhhh
I don't know! I'm crippled with indecision I just
Frevrevrevure
Uhh
Uhh.. I'm not not joking. I'm not doing this for a bit. I real i... Uh...
pftt
I
I...Just...
Umm
Uaaa!
Why is this so hard for me? Why is this so hard this uhh
This shirt says number one, I'm number one this shirts just a cool button-up that's prime I'm a cool button-up. Uhh...
MAYA! (finally)
God dammit. That was so hard. Let's see. Um, let's see, ah world name
A shit mother fuh
uhuhuhhhhhh
AAAAAAAAAAAAAH I'M LONELY!! ;-;
Okay, alright allow friends join? HAH! I don't have any friends, alright, let's do this LEROOOOOOOOOYYYY
Oh Jenkins, okay. There we go. Oh, okay. I am really light-headed. Whoa
Wayne?
How you doing, Wayne? Huh? Oh, I remember now
I remember how this game goes now. Oh, yeah, it's the same. Hoy-Yaaaa
Oh get ready for a whole lot of me being lonely
No, okay. Oh
Got em. Wayne don't even think about it, Wayne. Oh.. Pick up.
WAKE UP
*Incoherent words* humabumhum
Oh birb
*Incoherent*  hurhuruh Shake up!
*Incoherent* He's above the table
*Incoherent* huamahmh
Man I shouldn't sing ahhhhh
Bout to say I shouldn't sing so good or else I'll get a copyright claim *Incoherent* but fuck you
Oop
Nooo! How in the?
Pity tits did that miss? Uh, it's time to start building. How do I? Whoopsies. I'll take that hook, please.
How do I build why is the music so sweeping and grand fack off building hammer? I can't I can't do it
I can't do it boss.
(markimoo dying)
Thank you. Thank you. Alright now I can build building hammer. Can the not
Fack need to stop doing that, I'd be dead. All right, Wayne. I'm going out there
I'm gonna go get some you can just screw right off
Watch this shit, bro moves Wayne Brady ain't gonna get ain't good. Yeah, Wayne Brady ain't gonna get me. Oh,
I'm on my raft. Alright build craft
alright
Okay. Now I've got a building hammer. Oh
Wait, no. Arghh
Really whumped ya existence didn't I that's what you get for uhhh I..
Thank you. I mean, I don't know. I always I always mix up threats and compliments
Where's Wayne Brady Wayne Brady's all the way over there. So I'm going for it
I forget why's named Wayne Brady, but he absolutely is named Wayne Brady. That shark is one hundo Posentoe Wayne Brady
Oh did it?
Well, I did it.
OOH
I did it it's getting so peaceful. So relaxing so nice calm beautiful
LONELY
Crushing loneliness
the only thing I could ever hope for I guess I'll just
Do more of this whomp? Oh, I've got a big ol house. What else? Can I build axe?
That seems important. fishing rod
OoOoooOh
that's probably important I am gonna need food and water. Paddle?? "Has your raft stuck this wi-" what's it gonna get stuck on
Wayne Wayne
That's right Wayne you better back off, whoa
What is that
What is that?
WHAT IS THAT? Is that not that I'm coming towards me that is that is that coming towards me
Is that what I could get stuck on? Why is an island floating towards*gasp* am I floating towards the island? Oh
Shit. Well I this changes things I suppose. Right, I need more inventory.
I need more inventur. Hey Chow, Wayne. Whoa, Wayne, whoa
whoa
Dick dick, I guess. I just need to spread as wide as possible to kind of like threaten that Island
Oh, I am moving. *gasps* I am moving toward- Uh oh.
Well, tha, this is gonna be a problem
Where's my.. There's a...
This might this might be conundrum is what is that over there says someone else's raft
I didn't even know there were gonna be other people the whole point of this is that I'm lonely and
Nobody loved that's getting close. Hmm. That's gonna be a problem pretty soon; or a good thing?
Ah wow Wayne! Wayne get the fricken get off of my ah I can't
Oh I can't Wayne Brady you piece of sh, ohhhh
Well, I hope you're happy, you know, I hope you're happy cuz I'm not you know, I'm not happy
I just gonna say that right out. I'm not this is a problem. I'm gonna make a paddle..
I don't know what good's gonna do but
Scoop. All right. Okay. Well about to
LAND  HOOOO
WAYNE!
Good you rethought it. Okay, what's gonna happen when I hit this island?
Nothing can I get on the island what I can oh
That's so cool. Oh it's like a persistent world. Ooh red flower red flower hell yeah
Black flower?? All right raft. Wait, whoa. Whoa. Hey, whoa, where do you think you're going without me?
Come on now. Come on. Now. Let's go towards this thing. Hello. Could it be?
Friends. Oh, yeah. Oh, I'm really scoopin' a doopy on this one friend
Friend, look I'm not sea crazy. I am sea normal. I'm sea normal if you are senormal.
Come here. come to me. come to me. Come to come to me. come
come closer, you know you want to come to me
You want to say "Hi" O you like da size of my raft
I understand everybody get rafted jealous of me whenever they see
Hello, you are now marn. Mine. Got the crate. Uh-oh. No, I want more. I'm greedy. Oh shit
I shouldn't have been grown have been greedy. ahh ahh
Ugh! Sorry, I was greedy, but I got a crete
Where'd that thing go wait where did that?
Where'd my friend go?
This doesn't make any godd-. Where's everybody? Okay. I'm in the middle of absolutely dick diddily
I gotta get oh hi Wayne gotta get over here. All right Oh
sca-doodly doodly
doodly Doo Lu Doo Lu litter
I guess the trash flow is coming from over here now unless it decided to spawn in front of me. No, it's over there
God, you're a trick
It's over here Wayne Brady's just throwing me for a loop and I don't much appreciate that. Wayne Brady being an asshole
Well, you got to be an asshole now. Why are you named Wayne Brady ha? Oh
God, I'm *incomprehensible*. It's so cool man. They really improved this. Why are there waves?
Why does it look like the waves are getting bigger?
I don't like that at all. Also. What the hell are these things Oh
Plastic
I was not really growing no
Wayne no, no, no, no, no, no, no. No, so I wasn't really aiming for the plastic
I've only I'd known that I would have done zit. Ghibli. That is that plastic that better be plastic
Twofer I'm gonna get that one. Look at that. Watch that. What's this shit? Watch this shit Oh jump! Jump shot
They're actually gonna get it. I actually did I did not think I was gonna get that one. Oh,
Look how skilled I am. Oh look at me. I didn't really need to do that. But I did it anyway
Are you plastic oh yes, please? Pull the weight for this barrel
Doodle lee doodle doodle doo do
Doinky! Oh more plastic. Well don't mind if I do
Fuck fuck you, then go just think you're gonna run away from me? No, the answers. You are not. Oh why?
Wayne gahhh
Ughh
You asshole
Wayne you
piece of shit those cost plastic
I do not have a lot of plastic even though I know for a fact the ocean is covered in plastic
that's what everybody knows cuz we made it that way just in case we'd get trapped on a raft and then have to
Live off the plastic. That's why we did it. Why else would we do it? Oh, no, it's getting night.
Well, I'm gonna get real scared- whoops. I'm gonna get real scared tonight. Oh, it's beautiful Oh goddamn. Look at that
Look at that
That's beautiful
Sure. I'm glad people put all their shit in barrels man. That's really convenient. Alright, what else?
can we make. I want to make an axe!
Oh wait, I can make a rope
Very crude nail
Sure wet brick
Wet brick as opposed to what?
Not wet brick*claps* got him. No eventually, I'm gonna make where's my where's my chair the fuck music?
Where did you come from? I can research. Okay. I'm about to die from the lack of anything. Okay, I need water
Real bad. It's pretty. Oh god. It's so pro.
Oh! Yes
Love that. Okay. I have no water. I'm going to what I'm gonna do
I need to build a simple purifier. Yeah
Okay, I'm gonna make two of these. All right, you're gonna go you there and
Why should have made these sooner huh? Well, I need to oh, I am very dying. Okay plastic cup. All right, um
Fill with seawater and place cup of seawater place plank. Okay, I'm probably gonna die, but alright, okay
Well, there's a problem
Actually, no don't drink. Why did you drink that? Why did you drink that? I didn't want to drink that
That was not my idea to drink that Wayne
Brady's is gonna make fun of me now that I drank that how long do these take to do?
I kind of forgot that it was a important Oh filled with fresh water drink. Hey
WOW
Look at me
Look at me. Oh, look at me with my big brain. Oh
Yes, yes, please zomes. Yes, pleaseze to me zoms. Okay, get get.. Where where
Did I.. What by mad dog? I've got my hook
My hook
Ok, good thing I can make another one of those. Holy shit. Alright. I'm going to build one of these let's put this right there
Good god it alright. We're good. I didn't know this had limited durability hood
Somebody should probably keep it either survive it in this place real hard guys
I didn't even know Wayne Brady. You are gonna die if you come near me again
Ok, now that I'm not gonna die immediately. I need to figure out a food situation. Ok, so we need to make
*singing* Ahhh!
We need to make...
A fishing rod that'd be smart!
Make that I'm gonna make that no. Yeah, that's a good fishing rod and then we're gonna make a grill.
Oh hell yeah, oh let's build a grill baby. Grill baby grill Oh
Alley oop alright Oh hell's to the yeah. Give me you and give me you. Oh my god. I'm so good.
I am a god at this game. Oh, I'm so goddamn. Good. All right, so I'm gonna fishy wishy.
Got it got a raw mackerel put that baby on the grill place a plank down two planks.
You, you ass. Stop stop Is this working?  Why is this not working? Hey hey
Hey, wait, what why why did that? Why that not work?
Why if he does that to one of my oh, I thought I was assuming that I was gonna be
somewhat safe
but apparently I'm someone not safe the axe I guess the axe would be for when I if I get to an island and I
Uhhh.. Cut down a tree. Maybe I don't know maybe breaking up the shit that I have oh
What would even be the point that oh, okay.
That is then there's gotta be like a
Once I build a research table, there's got to be like something I could do then
Probably. Hard
It's hard
No, god, damn it. God. Oh, I
Drank seawater again because I'm an idiot. I can't daylight come I want to go home
I'm sorry, I'm getting grumpy . I didn't mean to get grumpy. I didn't mean to yell at you. That's that's not why we're here
We're here to have a good time alone in the ocean right have a good time. Oh dear daylight come Oh
Wayne Brady, you don't even think about it
You do not even think about that. Where'd my mackerel go? Oh, there it is. Yum yum yum in my tum tum tum. Pour that out
Fill, drink, fill, drink, ah, see how easy it is
There we go. Now we're now we're cooking with gas. Ooo. There's a another raft over there, man
I sure hope these uh other rafts are from people that were rescued and they didn't die horrible deaths
Alone on the ocean
Succumbing to the elements and uhhh
Wayne Brady here. Where's all my barrels by the way, are they gonna stop giving me barrels now, did they just decide that?
I don't deserve barrels. That's okay. Yeah, you know, it's fine. You know, I I don't really need barrels
It's just something that's incredibly useful to me was it was this?
Blueprint antenna?
FOR WHAT? For RESCUE? HUH screw rescue I've reserved my myself to be in here for the rest of forever
That's just how this is. I think there's no other way to do it. Like right there. I- just me and blah
You sack of sh- ok it good. You know what good good. You thought better of it. Raw tilapia.
I'll put some raw tilapia there. Okay now they go
AHHH uhh let me up
Okay, now that I got that? *screams*  I got that out of the way I'm good and we got uh- some barrels coming our way oh
There's a big wave.Why why wh-
Wow. Wow. Wow. Whoa, I don't like the smile on you. I wish I could whomp you. Why can I whomp you?
Whoa, that's is a big island. That's a big island. Waves it getting kind of big uh-
I don't know about the waves are getting kind of broad waves are
Kind of big uhhz. Well don't like them that big, you know, I like good wave but
Then some big waves are just saying, you know
Uh- eat this tilapia
Haven't been able to get any scrap metal.
Oh that's why the waves are getting kind of big. I'm- it's raining
They put weather in the game? Okay. Well, that's a problem shark bait wood and spur. That's what I was needing
Okay. I need to make a
Spear that's what's gonna kill this bad boy. Okay. All right. Did I miss any boy? It's all bye Island
Oh, whoa, where were we well. Okay research table. I've got a
researcher to ball aye
I don't know what that's gonna do for me, but I've got it and my raft is slightly girthier
Which is all that really matters in life when you really think about it
And if you're thinking about it the way I'm thinking about it then you're obviously smart
Like me~
Woo-woo-woo. These waves are girthy just like my
draft, I'm get you barrel
Ijh will get you and this plank to go. I'm gonna get this plastic. Ooh, that's it. So good
I am a triple Oh, baby. All right. Well we got here
Do I put this on that?
Whoa, whoa. Oh, not this time Sonny Jim. Not this time. You're gonna get Facebook spirit Oh Oh No!
Oh poor Wayne, Brody. Oh, no
What why
What did I piss off
Piss off the Sharks
The Sharks somber knell sad gonna run away his family. Just trying to chew some wood. Well too bad. Not my wood
Why the music?
Why?
I'm not sad
You can't make me sad
Cuz I'm not sad
You ain't gonna you ain't gonna make me sad if that's what you're trying to do cuz you ain't gonna work. I'm
sad proof
Hmm I don't like that I don't like that choir I
Ain't sad. It's just I'm not okay. I've farmed up a ridiculous amount of material. Oh
Wow, wow, wow, wow. Wow research
Wow
That's so good I think
Yeah, yes, I don't know what it what the hell did I just what did that do
I'm not sure what that did. Do I have to oh
Oh
Oh I get it, okay
So I've learned oh oh oh oh
That's an interesting way to do it. Okay. Wait, let me make sure I'm not missing anything
Barrel-like. All right, we're good. Okay. Oh and look at the waves are calming down and I see a raft over there
But I'm not gonna go for it, but other waves are coming down. I'm starting to learn things
So using my big old brain, nobody can appreciate it because nobody's here, but I'm using my big ol brain
Ain't that nice?
Say it's nice. It is nice. Thank you me a guy. I learned a collection net. I need to make rope
We're doing good lights are going out again, but that's okay. We've got more work to do. I'm gonna make some Nets I
Got to make sure I'm pointing in the right direction. But if I just make these nets no
Yeah
there and there oh
I'm gonna collect some items
Dust real nice. Oh
This oh, this is starting to become a home. Oh, this ain't just this ain't just this ain't just a house
This is a home now. That's nice
That's real nice
Wayne Wayne Wayne Wayne whoa! Whoa whoa Wayne
Wayne oh four more parts, uh
That's right
That is right that can make a mower collect. Hell, yeah. Oh, yeah, that's awesome
alright now that I got my resourcing operation started I can start building for
serials
Perfect. How about and them up? I've got the big bouncing the bales. Oh
Island Oh Oh
land ho I don't know what they say some kind of ho I
Did not a lady I want to be very clear. It's in this land. It's like dirt. I
Found dirt. Hello Island. Oh, is it a fruit tree Oh, that'd be so old
It'd be so good, but I can't I'm on a diet. Oh, I'm gonna die mass starvation diet
No, no, no way. No. No
No
Nah, you're gonna die soon. You're gonna die soon hate to say it, but you're gonna die soon
Is the way the world works
Silly bitch. Alright, so we got a lot of junk
We need to start thinking about what sale now that would be kind of cool. I need more palm-leaf
I'm not sure how good a sale would be
like at all, but
Oh
I'm sorry. I let things get to me. I take every loss personally and I shouldn't do that bird
When can I kill and eat a bird? That's all I'm really hoping for is worth a sweet succulent taste of bird
whoa
Whoa, these sail waves are getting kind of big don't know what that means. Okay, but I can make a sail now
Can nudge you in the right direction. What about the wrong drew? I like a this
I Like a this. Alright, let's open. Oh
Look at this ah
(Amazeplier) Look at da this Look at this. It's kind of taking on my view, but look at the disk Oh
Look at the dis Let's see if we can leave we can go this way. I want to go that other raft
Sail ho
Yeah, screw that other raft actually out of it. I have no desire
I've no desire to see that other raft and whatever riches it may entail. Alright small crop plot
I'm gonna need a couple of these we're gonna need to get our taters up and running
There you go there and you go
Right there, okay. We're gonna put taters in you
If I can get to it plant plant plant. Oh, it does three. That's lovely. Let's do beats plant plant plant
Oh, that's really nice. Oh, I need some fresh water. What kind of bullshit is this?
Okay, alright, then it needs fresh water, oh, all right then
Know that and yeah, something else needed fresh water in this son of a bitch. Okay. All right. Guess I'll just die
I guess I'll just starve and die. I don't know I didn't actually mean anything. I'll die
Oh, you'll do don't worry about I'll die. Yeah, I'll die. It's okay. Don't worry about I'll die. I'll eat these beets
Okay, no odd timing for music to suddenly pop in
Little concerning kind of wondering why isn't there all the time? Well, you know, yeah, we are booking it
We're also not getting nearly as much drops as I was hoping we were getting. Alright, let's see what else we can make
All right. We need rocks. I got rock. I got rock rope. No or did that
Metal. Yeah. Oh yeah. Oh
All these. Okay, I got those. Oh shit. What was that Oh,
Huh? What are that? Scrap hook? That sounds nice
Whoo, I learned about yourself. Ah
Look at you. I don't have enough scrap for that but doll. Look at you. Where am I gonna be more scrap?
Oh, I don't care. Look at you. You're cute faster more durable. It can be thrown farther
Yeah, just like your mom. Uh-huh can make paint. Oh, that's it. Seems unnecessary
Maybe I should make some storage. I probably need that. That's price. Sounds good Oh
Rotates smoothly. All right. Okay. Ah
No, no Wayne fucking oh
Yeah, look good. You did nothing. You're just such a piece of shit. Don't even think about it. I'll put you right there
Okay, I'm gonna put the flowers in there this weird black seed in there
We got a cook mackerel. I kind of forgot about Ernie. He did and yum yum yum come to Papa
No, that's not gonna come the pub came to Papa. All right, well
Let's see here. Those potatoes and beets are grown real good. Like I'm gonna venture need to build another one of those plots
But for now, we're doing pretty good. Okay, so what do I need?
Well, I mean eventually I'd need more collection nets
But I don't even have enough
Scrap to be able to make the nails to be able to get that in the first place
Maybe I could make myself a bed. That sounds nice
Maybe I deserve it. Maybe I deserve a nice bed
You know what? That's real love early like oh nice bed right there
Point down lay down. Oh
Dow sudden weird, okay. Alright. Well I get to contemplate my own mortality good fucked get fucked Wayne Brady
Maybe the least you know, that's some that's some alright could lay down. Look at the Stars harvest hell
Yeah, however, so harvest me harvest me do oh, you're not ready to harvest ok, whatever, bro
Nailed it oh
I'm so godlike
Wayne your stay away from my victories. Alright, so he's going good. I got a I got a damn good base here
I've got a shockingly. Good base. This is the base and this is pretty good now
the only thing I can do to get this better is just to make it wider but scrap metal is
Really hard to come by apparently ha ha Wayne Wayne Wayne
How are you not dead yet Wayne
Wayne are you not dead how in the hell?
Can't repair this there any way that I could repair this? I need to make more stuff. Ah
repair
One got him got him. Got him. Alright, let's see what let's oh shit. Let's see what this
Let's see what this guy is all about
Yeah, yeah we might scrape some paint here I'm not sure Allen
Could you all just the gentlest of kisses justic?
Okay, I was a little less gentle, but then I thought it was gonna be just the most gentle of kids
Alright, we're coming for you
Prepare to be boarded
Whatever that means, um, you'll get you don't run. You got some goodies over there. You got goodies. I can't
Oh, I know goodies when I see goodies and you got goodies
Come here you what do you think you going where your dinky guys waiting nowhere Oh
Nowhere, you ain't going nowhere. Can I break you down with like an axe or something? There's a bed here pickup crate. Oh
That's just stop Oh scary scary
Oh
My god
Why would you do that
What's up, what's up, but the full way, whoa
What the fake wood wood wood wood wood wood. Freakin to be said what?
Lay down, okay
Everything's still it's here. Good dolly. What the hell is that all about?
I mean, I know I was trying to eat my stuff but me ain't gonna happen on my watch
You crazy. Oh, I can cook a potato forgot. I can cook potatoes. Why am I I'm twisted. I don't like that
Hello my untwist my Scott damn it everything was going smoothly. I'm just gonna try to push. Can I push it?
Can I push it to twist it back? How do I how do I bushu?
Is this just cuz I hit something god dammit. Well now
All right, well this sucks, okay, anyway I am doing good I declare it and if I declare it I'm dry
I mean Brady if I declare it, then it's actually gonna be true Wayne you
Don't even think about it. Ah, so I'm gonna end this episode here. I'm the king
Hi, I wasn't able to build my screaming porch. How do you build the chair? Oh
I want a chair
wait
Wait, that's a lot of oh, that's a lot of stuff. I just learned. Oh, I
Like it. Ah, wait, wait, not that one not that one
You asshole are you bigger wait did you get bigger are you eating my wooden getting bigger?
That makes no sense. All right. Anyway, make this this go
Huh? All right this go
Oh how AM me do
You are in wrong spot remove you you are in way of my glorious glory
You go here you throw us towards that and we not rotate apparently
Okay, now me put didn't know how
How do this?
Well, no, maybe wall
wall wall
Sounds good, then put found douching
Nevermind not that no I am confused-ded
Okay
Whoa, I built wall
Can I bit why?
Why no?
This statute work. How do I bill?
How do I build?
Da shit god dammit. Oh, no. Oh, no. Wait. Um, oh wait. Oh wait. Oh,
No, no
I've somehow improved upon my screaming porch by making it an enclosed screaming room
I've trapped myself in a box. I
Have no
friends
No, one can hear my suffering I am alone
Anyway, I guess this is as good a place as any day in this episode
Maybe I'll pick this up if I can ever escape from this room!
Which I probably cannot anyway, thank you everybody so mu-
No!
Get away from my crops!
Well, there you have it and now I'm gonna die of dehydration. So thank you everybody someone for watching
also
We're going to Australia in November and Amsterdam in July tickets are available at tour.markiplier.com
Death is slowly enclosing in around me. So
Death is slowly in closing in around me. So
Thanks again everybody for watching. Let me know what you tought down the comments. And as always I'll see you in the next video
Thanks again everybody for watching. Let me know what you thought down the comments. And as always I'll see you in the next video
Buh bye!!!!
hi guys
its me subnaught
plz sub 4 more markiplier
ok byeeee
lol